so latest episode of severance
what do you mean i didn't say anything i
didn't say a single thing it was boring
boring i didn't say a single thing it's
boring
this is how i know i've been in a
relationship longer than you why because
you
don't have
the callous like the patience what it
feels like to show no that's i like the
show no the sleeping finishes you don't
have the ability to sit through what
feels like a pointless one-hour story
just to get the point at the end of it
ah
nice yes yeah
i'm seasoned in this nice nice i can sit
through 50 minutes of meaningless detail
and let it all come together right in
the last 60 seconds i go oh
so that's why i needed to know why you
were friends with that person and why
you went to the store earlier and oh
okay
damn
yeah no i'm just trying to be funny i'm
just trying to be funny i'm sending that
right to elena that that's fine
that's fine she knows that is true
though like you could have taken that
last 10 seconds and that could have been
the episode but that would be a guy's
version of the show yeah which is what i
would like i just want to know who dies
i want to see what happens the whole
[ __ ] thing the horse died
the whole [ __ ] thing
the whole [ __ ] thing was building up
to that moment two episodes now that
this has been their goal just get it
[ __ ] done so in a in a film right you
have three acts okay yeah so
you know in a similar fashion here
we've got different
moments in the whole story so this i
think would be like the third act where
it's all coming together yeah but in a
tv show is it isn't it a little bit
different no but like yellowstone for
example you have six acts yeah yeah
right first step in the first episode
yeah fair fair six acts and yeah two
people die
yeah yeah it's i guess it is hard when
you come off yellowstone to go back to
several yes it is you're like i just saw
50 people die and two horses is
yellowstone written by dudes because
that's maybe what's going on here it for
sure is written by three dumb guys 100
it literally is i literally it's like
they got they went to like it's like
they found the three just dumbest people
just dudes and like even written before
nah three frat guys went to film school
exactly
shot a banger promovid for our pledge
class though all right i think you guys
will be perfect i'm looking up who wrote
severance hold on it was written by a
man it was hold on yeah and then uh the
writer of yellowstone was just inducted
into the texas cowboy hall of fame
yeah see there you go i'm really
cheering on women right now yeah and
complaining about their stories it is
undeniable that uh when you're in a
relationship a hetero relationship as
the man i think you listen to more
stories than you tell
because i think guys naturally leave out
details and it's just because we're like
i don't know we kind of like one track
mine what what happened i went to the
store and then yeah like this this van
blew up on the way what the [ __ ] like
you just yeah i don't know
it just blew up yeah the guy's making
meth in there what there's people making
meth that man is like three blocks from
the house well they're no longer making
matters yeah i guess we're safe then no
but okay so severance like yeah i'm
still really enjoying it and i and i
just i don't know it feels like a lot of
like fluff now
without progressing the story
[Laughter]
the waffle party was [ __ ] good though
that was wild
and the egg [ __ ] beforehand yeah so good
yeah
that [ __ ] it just leaves you just
feeling so empty four people in an
office room eating eggs yeah with like
light music playing and the napkins and
the plastic cups it just makes you feel
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah doesn't it it
reminds me of every corporate party i've
ever been to but on steroids yeah it's
like crazy that's why it's awesome i
know it's awesome but it's that was in
the first episode you got that dude did
the waffle party not only was that
creepy i was geeked because so those
paper mache masks they made i went down
like a rabbit hole and they're i think
it's a film from the 20s
shot on super eight it leans into that
theme like heavy and i was like damn
it'd be cool like make something with
[ __ ] like that and so i talked like some
practical effects people and they're
like oh yeah no those are totally custom
like you have to make those from scratch
like
paper mache but really intense just
from the time it took to make that [ __ ]
i was geeked on that i was like oh i
know that took like 50 hours and then to
see four more of them come out i was
already creeped out when he was sitting
there on the bed yeah it was creepy and
also i was like what does this have to
do with anything i need to know yeah
like why is the whole show that seems
like it has nothing to do with anything
how does that relate why was she acting
like a [ __ ] midwife who the boss that
got fired and now it's like seems like
that's just forgotten no i think it's
all gonna come together she's a creep i
think mark was like her little thing i
think she was like obsessive girl who
went through like keir camp lumen camp
and then went her way up the ranks and
like idolized his care the whole thing
is just a cult i mean i think it's
deeper than a cult i think we'll figure
that out like a way exaggerated version
of steve jobs and apple sort of yeah i'm
pumped to see them wake up what a
cliffhanger i know that's why i had to
go watch that horse die one more time
so you could go to sleep yeah
so you could i did not get whatever
that's your eye bleach easy
[Laughter]
you